[موسيقى]
صبرا تري في طريقها إلى أول
موعد لها ، وهي تعمل بالطاقة الشمسية Sahay Li وهي
بائعة لمنتجات الطاقة الشمسية تم توظيفها من قبل
الشركة الرائدة في السوق
وعملائها من بين الملايين الذين يعيشون
خارج الشبكة وقد لا تكون ولاية راجاستان
في يوم نيكاه  كان كل شيء
يقتل ، من الصعب للغاية العيش
بدون كهرباء
عندما أزور هذه المنازل ، أخبرتني النساء
أنه خلال فصل الصيف يحدث انقطاع التيار الكهربائي في
كثير من الأحيان كنا نحرق الكيروسين ولكن
المنازل مصنوعة من الطين ويمكن أن تشتعل فيها
النيران وقد حدثت وفيات
تعمل بالطاقة الشمسية  المنتجات تجعل الحياة أسهل بكثير
، الألواح الصغيرة والمشاعل الأكثر مبيعًا ،
تعد العروض القوية جزءًا
من
مؤسس الوظيفة IG Tasha Solar Suhail II كان مشروع سهيل الثاني
محركًا رئيسيًا للنجاح اليوم ، حيث أن
ثلاثة آلاف من منتجات Sahil E's الشمسية
تلبي بالفعل أكثر من نصف مليون
أسرة احتياجات عندما يكون ذلك  فيما يتعلق
بتحديات الطاقة النظيفة ، فهم لا يقومون فقط
بتوصيل فوائد الطاقة النظيفة
ولكنهم يساعدوننا الآن في
فهم ماهية  إعادة الابتكارات الجديدة التالية
المطلوبة لإدخالها لتلك الأسرة الريفية للمساعدة في
سد الفجوة عندما يتعلق الأمر
بتحديات حياتهم.
لقد تحول العمل الذي يقترن منتجاتهم بخلق فرص عمل إلى أرباح أخيرًا ، في
اليوم الذي يطارد
فيه الناس العميل الريفي لأنهم يريدون
منحهم المنتجات والخدمات
وهم يعيشون بسعادة في تلك القرية
دون الحاجة إلى الانتقال إلى حي فقير حضري
هو يوم  بأنك حققت نجاحًا ،
John Tefft arias CNN Jaipur India